[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "TESTIMONY"]
ERIN MACKEY: Hi.
I'm Erin Mackey and
I play May Catlett
in the show which-- Vince
just sang a song that's
John Newton's song.
He's the main person we
follow throughout the story,
and Mary Catlett was the love
of his life, his childhood love.
And the song Vince just sang is
really a moment in John's life
where he finally kind of
sees the wrongdoing he's
been doing-- how
he's been living
his life has been really bad.
And Mary-- and she
was a real person,
all these people they
were really alive--
and she always believed in him.
She believes that
he could change.
She just believed that there
was more in him than what
he was doing with his
life and that there
was so much good in him still.
So, this song I'm going to sing
is called "I Still Believe."
[MUSIC  - "I STILL BELIEVE"]
[APPLAUSE]
LAIONA MICHELLE: Hello there.
My name is Laiona Michelle.
I'm so happy to be here.
I play the role of Nanna, a
house slave from Sierra Leone.
And I'm going to sing for
you a song called "Daybreak."
It's the song that
encourages Mary
to find the light
within herself in order
to be the voice of the
abolitionist movement.
[MUSIC - "DAYBREAK"]
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
Good afternoon.
The hits keep coming.
My name is Charles E. Wallace.
And this particular
song takes place
in the second act
of the show where
Thomas, John Newton's
manservant-- slave--
has just been betrayed by him.
And this is the answer
to that betrayal.
I give you "Nowhere
Left to Run."
[MUSIC - "NOWHERE LEFT TO RUN"]
[APPLAUSE]
ERIN MACKEY: Shall
we set this one up?
OK.
Yup!
This next song actually
happens earlier in the show.
Again, my character
Mary Catlett--
she is becoming aware of
the reality of slavery
and the horrible
abuse of these people
and oppression of these people.
And she is starting
to ask questions.
It takes place in
1744 England, so this
is very early on in England's
move toward abolition.
And she meets some
people in her town
who are fighting
against this injustice
and they're trying to get her
on board for this song called
"We Are Determined."
[MUSIC - WE ARE DETERMINED"]
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Why do you feel
like nobody has-- at least
personally I feel
like a lot of people
have not heard of John Newton.
Like, he is the author
of one of the songs
that is sung everywhere.
Everyone knows "Amazing Grace."
So where-- hi--
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: You know,
when I first was introduced to
this property, I was mortified,
embarrassed.
I mean, I considered
myself well-read
and I couldn't believe I
didn't know this story.
I mean, he is more important
than Abraham Lincoln, Martin
Luther King, on and on and on.
He is the man who began
the abolitionist movement.
I guess 200 years from now
we're probably not going
to remember a lot of
people, but we're really
thrilled to be bringing him at
the forefront of the culture
and into the Broadway community.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
why do you think--
why do we think that is?
That, I mean, in America
we're taught specifically
the history of
America, which is just
Abraham Lincoln pretty much.
After I saw the show-- I
saw the show last week,
and it was phenomenal.
And I went home
and I immediately
started researching
all about John Newton
and about the British
side of all this.
And was like, oh I thought
America did all this but like--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
Well, we were British.
ALAN SEALES: Right,
we were British.
Right, so how much did
you guys individually
learn about this once you
started with the organization,
with the show?
ERIN MACKEY: Well, for me,
I just started with a show
last year.
Some people have been with
it much longer than that.
But I auditioned for the show
and I didn't know anything
about John Newton.
I read the script and
I was like, oh wow,
they really made a really
cool dramatic story.
This can't possibly be true.
And it's real.
I was like this is
stranger than fiction.
I spoke to the
director on the phone
and I remember asking him,
how much of this is true?
And he's like--
there's this character,
this princess character.
I was like, oh she's made up.
No, she's not.
She's real.
I was like, wow!
I couldn't believe just how
incredible, truly, stranger
than fiction his life is.
I mean, he was a
slave trader, who
was then enslaved
and then became
a leader of the
abolitionist movement.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
And branded a slave.
ERIN MACKEY: And branded.
I mean, it's just incredible.
So I knew nothing,
and then I've learned.
CHARLES E. WALLACE: And being
with the show since 2009
when we did the first
reading, and when
we had our first production
at Goodspeed in 2012,
the director gave each of
us an assignment basically
that had something to
do with that period.
So once you've done that
research and you're like,
wow, all of this is happening.
So that's how a lot of
us have come to know
that period and John Newton.
ERIN MACKEY: And
it takes place--
our story takes place in so many
different places in the world.
It takes place Sierra Leone.
It takes place in
Barbados, in England.
So the research we did
was quite extensive.
ALAN SEALES: What was the
audition process like?
You mentioned that you just came
in blind, right, pretty much?
ERIN MACKEY: Well, my
story's kind of strange
because this isn't
how it normally goes.
I mean, I've auditioned
and I've been in many shows
and you know, you usually
have to go several times.
This one just-- I think
really was just meant to be.
I was out of town doing a
show and I was in California.
I couldn't be there
for the audition.
So I put myself on tape, which I
think you did too, right, yeah?
Yeah, I put myself-- I videoed
myself singing some songs
and doing some scenes.
And I know they had been
looking for a long time
and they were pretty--
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: I remember
Pat McCorkle the casting agent
calling me and saying, well,
Erin Mackey can't come in.
You're going to have to
audition her on tape.
And I said, there is no way
I'm hiring the lead actress
in our musical off of a tape!
ALAN SEALES: And here she sits.
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
Famous last words.
ALAN SEALES: Here she sits.
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: And then I
watched the first 15 seconds
of her audition on tape
and I was--
ALAN SEALES: Done?
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: Oh my gosh.
ERIN MACKEY: Irene, thank you.
Off of a tape.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
That's totally true.
ERIN MACKEY: And then I spoke
to the director on the phone,
and that's sort of just sealed
in all and I came on board.
So that was my experience.
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: But, Laiona,
you've been with us
since the beginning too.
LAIONA MICHELLE:
Yeah, yeah, it's
been six years from
the very first reading.
And before then I
was doing just a lot
of new plays, a lot of new
workshops, many of which
continue without
me because that's
just how the business goes.
But this one really
fell on my lap.
And it was like a blessing
to walk in the room,
to not know anything about
this story of "Amazing Grace,"
and to just go in there.
And it was a monologue,
I believe, at the time.
And then the role grow
into a principal role
with a beautiful song.
How lucky am I to get to
sing such wonderful material
like "Daybreak?"
ERIN MACKEY: I just get
to listen to it on stage
every night.
ALAN SEALES: That was amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah that was one of the
two parts where I cried.
When you did your
number I was like--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
What was the other part?
ALAN SEALES: I'm not
going to give it away.
I don't want-- it's--
ERIN MACKEY: It's a
bring your tissue--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: How
about the end of the first act?
Was that amazing?
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
Yes.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
I'm not telling them.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, go see it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
Our set designer,
Eugene Lee-- one of the
prolific set designers
in this country "Wicked,"
on and on and on-- he
created something at
the end of the act
that you will not
see anywhere else.
ERIN MACKEY: Oh my goodness.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
Anywhere else.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, it was
amazing So going back like six
years though, both of
you, Charles and Laiona,
you guys have been with it
from-- since what initial--
like, you've got a script and--
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
Since the first read.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: I
wouldn't even call it a script.
We had a couple of ideas.
ALAN SEALES: And, Carolyn,
you were involved,
you were with it the
whole way too, right?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So-- go ahead.
CHARLES E. WALLACE: I was--
what was your question.
ALAN SEALES: Oh,
I was going to ask
Carolyn what an executive
producer does, but I--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
I mean, first you
have to find the material
you want to work on
and then you have
to raise the money.
ALAN SEALES: Oh.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
It's a very expensive show.
I'm sure you can see that.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, I bet.
I bet, yeah.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: There's
30 something people on it.
It's a very, very
expensive show.
ALAN SEALES: The Nederlander is
not cheap real estate either.
Yeah.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: So
you have to find the property.
You have to develop
the property.
You've got to go and
try it out a few places.
We went to Goodspeed
Opera House.
Then we went to Chicago, to
the Bank of America Theater.
And then we came and waited
for a theater in New York.
And in the meantime you
have to keep raising money,
raising money.
And we were fortunate
enough to have raised
enough to open on Broadway.
So, you know, the
next step for this
is hopefully to have a long run.
ALAN SEALES: So
what happens though.
Like, can you get to a
point where you're like,
oh, we're this close, we're
this close to Broadway
and then you just don't get
money and it just goes away?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
Yeah, lots of shows.
Most shows.
ERIN MACKEY: Yeah, that
happens to most shows.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
You've probably
been involved in lots of those.
Yeah.
VINCE ODDO: And it's
not only just the money,
it's to the actual space.
I mean, we were waiting around
for a theater for the longest
time.
People were like, well, I
don't know about this show.
I don't know about this.
Everyone's like,
well-- they think they
want the next biggest thing.
They're willing to do whatever.
Or there's months in advance
where people have already
had theaters booked.
So we were just kind of like,
when is it going to happen?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: If you
have a show that was a movie,
you're in better shape--
ALAN SEALES: "Newsies"?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
than in the show.
Well, "Newsies" happened
to be wonderful.
ALAN SEALES: It was very good.
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: It's just
there's so many
movie musicals now
people think, oh well, you've
got a built in audience.
But in our show,
you actually don't
know how it's going to end when
you walk in the door, right?
ALAN SEALES: Right.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
So you're like this.
And you're really
engaged because you don't
know how it's going to end.
And I think that's
more interesting.
ERIN MACKEY: Yeah, it's what
people who I've had come
see the show are
just so-- they just
don't know what's
going to happen.
And that's fascinating.
And it's just kind of becoming
rarer on the Broadway stage--
to see something that
is truly unknown.
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
Original, yes.
ERIN MACKEY: Original.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, this
is totally original.
And the music is-- it's
got that classic feel.
It's got that-- it's
got that "Les Mis" feel,
for lack of anything else.
And it is that
something personally
that drew you guys to the show?
Or was it a conscious
decision on the--
from the writer and
the composer to make
it sound a little bit
older because it's
set in 1744, right?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Well,
the first thing that I heard
was a website-- I
went to a concert
in the basement of the
Empire State Building,
and there were like
about 10 songs.
And I think only a couple of
them are still in the show.
But the three that
I fell in love with,
I went back to my
office-- because I've
been producing theater
for a long time--
and I got on the website and I
sent them to three friends who
are dead hard commercial
theater people, and I said,
what do you think
of these songs?
And they emailed me back,
goosebumps, goosebumps.
And I was like, OK,
so I think we've
got the beginnings of
something really great here.
You know, when a piece of
music can move you that way.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I'm
still singing the finale,
the song you guys sang.
In my head, I'm (HUMMING).
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: We do sing
"Amazing Grace" in the show.
ALAN SEALES: And
it is phenomenal.
Great-- great,
great arrangement.
So what has changed
other-- I mean,
you said that songs
have been dropped.
Have your character--
oh right, no, it
was the character of Nanna
was not a principal character
at first.
Like, how has the show grown?
What's different?
LAIONA MICHELLE: Ah, let's see.
It's grown so much.
I will say this, that we say
all the time that theatre is
a collaborative art, and it
really, really, really is.
This room just from
the rehearsal process
has been so open.
We have been in a room
where the writers were
able to let the artists, the
actors, play so much and improv
and help flesh out the scenes
and inspire the dialogue.
And I have never had an
experience like that.
All the way up to
previews we had maybe
about 20 pages per day
of just massive changes.
And they have really
just been open to us
in the entire process.
Yeah.
So a lot, a tremendous
amount has changed.
ERIN MACKEY: Even-- even
just from Chicago to here,
which is only a matter of
what was it, six months?
Yeah.
And a lot of the
show did change.
We learned a lot
in Chicago, learned
about the structure of it and
how the audience follows it.
I think all the
characters became--
just were deepened in
terms of the-- yeah,
the back stories and--
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: The thing
about a musical, on any
musical that you work on--
and I've worked on a lot of
musicals-- the composer ends up
with a trunk full of songs
that he's thrown out.
And they become the
inspiration for the next work.
Because we've probably
thrown out eight to 10,
12 songs in the process.
And great songs.
ALAN SEALES: Wow, there's like
30 in the show already, right?
I mean there's--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
But we've replaced some.
You know, there were a couple
of songs that the sailors sang.
We were like, those sailors
wouldn't sing those songs.
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
(SINGING) In the ocean.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
(SINGING) In the navy.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: A bar song.
We had songs in a (SINGING) bar.
You know, they're all gone.
But they're going to be in
his next show, I'm sure.
ALAN SEALES: The song
about sailors in a bar.
That-- I'll go see that.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
"Sailors In a Bar,"
that's the next musical.
ALAN SEALES: So the
show is set in 1744
at the height of the
British slave trade.
And of course, like,
the two main topics
of the show-- in case you
guys didn't pick up on it--
are slavery and racism, which
are two very big topics still
today that people are
uncomfortable talking about.
I mean going into the
readings and the rehearsals
were-- I guess, you as
a producer or you guys
as actors-- were any of you
worried about any backlash
or anything negative that may
come out of it from an audience
perspective?
VINCE ODDO: I think
our job as actors
is to tell the
story to its most--
to the umpteenth
version of truth.
And, you know, if that is a hot
button thing for some people--
our job is to tell it with
the most truths possible.
And if that is uncomfortable
for some people, that's fine.
That's the reason we do things.
ERIN MACKEY: That's
part of theater.
VINCE ODDO: Yeah.
Yeah.
And the reason why we create.
And if you could move some
people to feel some things,
that is the reason we do this.
So yes, it's uncomfortable.
And race and racism is obviously
very prevalent today with
what's been happening, but
that is--that's our job,
to move people to feel things,
to inspire conversations like
this one.
ALAN SEALES: Mhm.
CHARLES E. WALLACE: And, during
the process while working
on the show when,
say for instance, we
got to a particular scene when
they brought the slaves out
to be sold, it was a bit
uncomfortable in the room
because you're not used to
dealing with that every day.
But the director and the
artistic staff, everybody
made it-- it was a
safe place in the room
so you could talk
about those issues.
And then at the end
of the day, yes, it
is our job to tell the story.
But if once you know that
you are in a safe place
and everybody in this room-- we
all have the same goal in mind,
then you go on about
your business as an actor
and you do the job
and tell the story.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: And
our Director, Gabe Barre,
is the most gracious human
being on the face of the earth.
He is kind and patient
and never raised his voice
or had any kind of artistic
flair up in the room.
So he was-- really created
the space for the conversation
between the actors.
And now the actors have created
the ability for the audiences
to have the conversation.
And I can tell you,
on any given night
you can show up at the theater.
It's a very diverse audience
and people are crying.
And people are
speaking to each other.
And it is really
a perfect moment
in time for this musical.
We didn't plan it
that way, it's one
of those divine
interventions that our show
has opened at this
period in time
when people really need
to have this conversation.
I can't believe we're in 2015
and we're still saying this,
but we are.
ALAN SEALES: So,
have you-- has there
been anything bad from critics
or audience members that
have come in at all?
Do you get hate mail?
I mean--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
Not hate mail.
ERIN MACKEY: I haven't
gotten any hate mail.
VINCE ODDO: At the stage
door every night people
are just so inspired.
I think that's what it
always comes down at the end.
No one's is disagreeing with
anything that's happening,
they're just moved in a way.
And that's-- we've done exactly
what we sought out to do is
move these people in
a way that's like,
oh my goodness this
really happened.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Yeah.
VINCE ODDO: How can I look
at myself in the mirror
and do better?
Just generally do better.
That's kind of my, how I've--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Yeah.
I think some of the New
York cynical critics
can't really embrace the fact
that people are feeling things.
But isn't that why
you go to the theater?
Don't you want to
feel something?
I mean, it's an
expensive ticket.
I hope you want to do more
than just be entertained.
And this is very
entertaining, but it also
makes you feel something.
ERIN MACKEY: It makes you think.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Yeah,
it makes you really think.
But you will also leave
having had a great experience.
But one of the critics
from some offshoot magazine
said that we planted
people to stand.
And I can tell you
that every night--
ALAN SEALES: During
the curtin call?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Yeah.
I mean is that possible?
You were there.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: People
just jump to their feet.
It happens every night.
They just couldn't believe it.
They didn't want to
believe that it happens.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LAIONA MICHELLE: I know for me--
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
Raise their hands
ALAN SEALES: There's
a lot of feelings.
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
They touch people
they don't even
know next to them.
It's amazing.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: But
you can be alone if you want.
You know, if you want
your private space.
CHARLES E. WALLACE:
But it's amazing.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
because you do
sort of an audience sing-along,
I guess, with "Amazing Grace."
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: We
didn't plan it that way,
but in Chicago when it
happened we were like, wow.
And then I said to our
director and writer,
I said, maybe when
we come to New
York we need to revisit this.
Let's, like, put it on
hold and see what happens.
And so we watched and the first
couple of nights, same thing.
We're like, OK, go.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
people like singing it.
ERIN MACKEY: Well,
there are so few songs
that-- it used to be such a
cultural thing in society--
everyone kind of
knew the same songs.
It was something that
you did together,
but that's phased out so much.
But it's "Happy Birthday"
and "Amazing Grace."
I mean people-- those
are the songs we know.
And so it's exciting.
You're like, I know this
song, and I'm feeling so much.
Like, I can sing it!
ALAN SEALES: That's funny.
So audience, if you
guys have any questions,
there's two mics in the
aisles for you to ask.
Feel free to come up any time.
So, Vince, John Newton,
I would like to play him,
do I need big biceps?
VINCE ODDO: No, that's
not correct [INAUDIBLE].
No, not at all.
ERIN MACKEY: But
it's not a bad trait.
ALAN SEALES: How demanding
is the role John Newton?
Like, he's in every scene.
He's all over the place.
He's like getting
tied up or beaten
or jumping around or, yeah.
VINCE ODDO: I've always
approached the theater business
or acting business in the way
that you would kind of-- I'm
from a big sports background.
And--
ALAN SEALES: (DEEP
VOICE) Obviously, yes.
VINCE ODDO: If you
can't tell all ready.
No, but it's true.
You have to-- you
have to have your body
and be mentally
sharp at all times.
And that's for-- and
I think for anything
that you-- that I personally
want to be successful for,
I just want to be at my best.
The role of John
Newton is a lot.
It's vocally tiring, one.
As well as physically tiring.
You're getting beat.
You're getting-- there's all
sorts of explosions, fights.
So you have to be
in as best shape
as you personally
can, and I feel
the most comfortable
being in the shape
that I'm in for any show.
Doesn't have to be this one.
Or, but--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
Vince was also
in "Rocky," so thus the biceps.
ALAN SEALES: Ah, OK.
It all comes full circle now.
What have you enjoyed
about playing John
Newton versus other characters?
VINCE ODDO: Um,
he's a terrible guy.
In the beginning of the play
it's-- the arrogance and flair
that you could have being
someone is just-- I'm not--
I'm totally not John
Newton in my normal life,
so to be able to do that--
to do the role and just have
a humongous transformation
going from Act One to Act Two.
And seeing what you've
done in the past-- how
ever many years in
the play it is-- just
having that reconciliation
with oneself
and the redemption
that he goes through.
He's the most difficult
person I've ever played.
And it's-- I think there's so
much beauty in the fact that
there's this man who was so
wretched and awful who comes
literally full circle to
help start the abolitionist
movement.
You know, someone who is
the son of a slave trader.
And it's just a very
complicated person.
As an actor it's like
I felt-- you've like
fallen in a gold mine.
Of course you want to
do something that moves
people in some sort of way.
And I think that's who John
Newton is, and it's fun.
ALAN SEALES: Huh.
Yeah.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you
for coming to Google,
and thank you for that
excellent performance.
I really want to see the play.
CAST: Yay!
Great!
Good!
ERIN MACKEY: Come see the play!
AUDIENCE: And then, you've
already answered my question.
But I'm curious for
the other actors, what
types of roles or
characters have
you played in the past
which prepared you
for the roll you're
currently playing?
Just for people who haven't
seen the musical yet,
sort of-- like what are
similar characters to those
you're currently playing?
ERIN MACKEY: I have to say that
before we did the production
in Chicago, I had done
"South Pacific" at two
different theaters last
year and I played Nellie.
And a huge-- I mean, the end
of Act One of "South Pacific"
is it being revealed
that Nellie is racist.
That she has been
taught certain things.
She grew up in Little Rock,
Arkansas, and it's 1940s
and she does not
see the Polynesians
that she meets in the South
Pacific as bean equals.
And and it's a very dark
place to go as an actor,
but it was very helpful to me
as I started this because that
is where these people are.
Mary begins there.
John begins there.
They do not believe that
these people are equals.
And that is the realization
they make, thank god.
You know, but for
me that was very
helpful-- was to have kind of
stepped in those shoes before.
Different, very
different circumstances
but similar human issues.
So for me that was helpful.
LAIONA MICHELLE: Yeah, I feel
like the majority of my career
I've been leading up to
playing this role of Nanna
that I based off
of my grandmother.
I've played a number of maids
and slaves throughout my life.
But I also had the opportunity
to play Ida B. Wells who
was a trailblazer in the civil
rights movement who started
the anti-lynching campaign.
So the spirit of Ida B. Wells
fused with my grandmother, who
worked as a maid for the
majority of her adult life,
really prepared
me for this role.
Yeah, to give a voice
to all the Nannas
out in the world that
don't have the voice
CHARLES E. WALLACE: I think
whether it's playing this role
or-- I did John
in "Miss Saigon"--
or any other role is first
and foremost is staying up
on your craft.
You know, it's continuing
to work on your voice, voice
lessons, maybe acting class here
and there, physical movement.
And then after
that, this story--
this play being based
on a true story,
as was "Saigon," for
some reason for me when
there's real truth
there basically--
and you've done the research
as the director had us
do-- then you just take all that
information and you go with it.
So that that's what works
for me is the research
and basically staying
up on your craft.
ALAN SEALES: What kind of--
you mentioned the research
earlier too.
What kind of research
did the director
have you do to
prepare for the show?
I mean, you just went
off and picked something
to learn about?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ERIN MACKEY: He actually
gave us assignments,
we got stuff like
homework assignments
for the first day of rehearsal.
CHARLES E. WALLACE: There
were like 30 assignments
so you got to hear everyone.
VINCE ODDO: Two full
days of rehearsal.
ERIN MACKEY: Everything
from authentic-- the dance
of the period in
and Sierra Leone.
The dance of the
period in England.
The--
DAN: Christmas celebrations.
ERIN MACKEY: Christmas
celebrations in England.
DAN: Cricket.
ERIN MACKEY: Sports.
VINCE ODDO: How many
sailors were on the ship.
ERIN MACKEY: The Navy.
VINCE ODDO: Their
living quarters.
There's--
ERIN MACKEY: A war.
VINCE ODDO: --32, 33
different assignments.
And we spent two days,
eight hours a day
just sitting in a
huge room learning
so much about each other
and homework assignments.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Is the entire
play set in 1744 or does it
cover some of the later
periods of his life?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
We compress his story
into two years.
Because truly John Newton
didn't write "Amazing Grace"
until much later in his life.
So we sort of compresses
his life into two years.
So historically not exactly
accurate, because that fight
took 20 years.
AUDIENCE: Well it
took until what?
1840s and Wilberforce
helping to finish--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Well,
he was William Wilberforce's
mentor.
AUDIENCE: I knew that.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The other
question is, when
you were thinking
about this, did you--
you reminded me of another play
with another nasty slave trader
who converts in "The Mission."
Did you think at all about that?
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: No,
but that's a beautiful movie.
It's a gorgeous movie
with a gorgeous score.
Really beautiful.
ALAN SEALES: So Erin,
ERIN MACKEY: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Along with-- hi.
ERIN MACKEY: Hi.
ALAN SEALES: Along
with the other topics
that of course we've
been talking about,
the role Mary Catlett is
that of a strong woman
in a time when women were
not supposed to be that way.
So, how did you find this
proper balance of being
the demur single woman
which, of course being
single at an older--
and I know even
know how old she's
supposed to be actually.
ERIN MACKEY: In the show
she's about-- she's 18, 19.
I mean, she's like prime time--
ALAN SEALES: Oh yeah.
ERIN MACKEY: for
getting married.
ALAN SEALES: It's like
very marrying age, right?
ERIN MACKEY: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So was that
difficult to find a balance
between being what-- playing
a character that people were
supposed to expect a certain
way versus actually, like,
finding inner strength--
ERIN MACKEY: Absolutely.
ALAN SEALES: --for
this character?
ERIN MACKEY: That's what's
been probably my favorite thing
about Marry and
playing her is the fact
that she is so
progressive at a time
where she had no rights, really.
I mean, she didn't.
And she's speaking up for
people who have no voice,
and she has no power.
I mean, she's finding ways
to assert power in a society
that she does not
have many ways.
And she's willing to die for it.
I mean, it's-- yeah it's
definitely-- you know,
she's working
within her society.
She's working within
her conditions.
So she's-- I mean, she's kind
of playing the game sometimes.
But she's trying to use
it to her advantage,
and use it to make a
difference in her society.
So that's one of
my favorite things
about Mary is that-- what you
just said-- is that obstacle,
is that just back and forth
for her and that struggle.
And that she-- and that
she decides that, I
know what I'm supposed to do.
I know what society tells me
to do, but it's not right.
And I can't stand
for it anymore.
ALAN SEALES: Even against advice
from your Nanna who was like,
don't-- don't do it.
Don't rock the boat.
Like, everything's good.
Yeah.
Don't get involved.
ERIN MACKEY: Absolutely.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
I'm a big Broadway fan.
So my question is, what
is something, like,
memorable or profound that
someone has said to you
at stage door or something.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, good one.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
That's a good question.
CHARLES E. WALLACE: Real
recently-- before someone else
takes this-- the
other day there was
a woman from Sierra Leone
who was at the show,
and part of our show is
based in Sierra Leone.
And her name was Yema, as is one
of the characters in the show.
So when things like that happen,
it's-- like that happened.
And then the other-- on
Sunday afternoon a lot
of times when we're singing
the last chorus of "Amazing
Grace" and people just one
at the time get up and start,
and it makes you
cry onstage-- those
are some of the most
memorable moments for me.
LAIONA MICHELLE: I
think the most memorable
for me was having a
conversation with my nephew
who just completed his first
year at Hampton University.
So he comes-- and he's
staying with me for summer.
And he, you know, he
was at opening night,
and we had a conversation
the next morning.
And I said, so, Jay, what
did you think about the show?
And he was like, Auntie,
to be honest with you,
I am still processing.
That was a lot of information.
I was deeply moved, and
I'm still processing.
It shook me.
And I thought it was beautiful
that he articulated that,
and that he is processing.
And I think that's the
point of this show.
You know, theater
has to be reachable.
And it's not going to
always be comfortable.
I'm extremely uncomfortable
playing this role,
but I know that's what I'm
supposed to be in order
for this piece of art to reach.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: I've
produce a lot of musicals,
but I've never
produced a musical
where people will come up
to you and say, thank you
for doing this.
It was almost like a movement
or something, you know?
Thank you for stepping out
and-- I mean it's a high risk.
You are in the business
of following trends
and, you know, we're bucking a
big trend and it's a high risk,
but it's really a valuable risk.
And I think the appreciation
from the audience
to the actors, as well to
me, has been so unusual.
ALAN SEALES: Hmm.
So, Laiona, congrats on your
Broadway debut, by the way.
Yeah?
[CHEERING]
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Wonderful.
So you mentioned-- you mentioned
that your character makes
you feel uncomfortable, which
is, I guess a good thing,
but-- like all of you-- I
guess this question goes out
for all of you-- that you have
to do this powerful, emotional
heartbreak-- bring yourself
into this heartbreak eight times
a week.
Like, is that difficult
for you to go through this?
I mean, like, is seeing--
the show I watched--
it was one show, and I felt
like you put everything
you had into this one moment!
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: They do.
They really do.
ALAN SEALES: I mean, like how--
ERIN MACKEY: I watch a lot
of really crappy reality TV
to just like totally turn off.
CAROLYN ROSSI
COPELAND: Yes, you do.
ERIN MACKEY: Like you can
totally separate for a while.
I'm like, all right,
give me some--
ALAN SEALES: Right.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: A lot
of "Bachelorette" going on.
Which is over.
ERIN MACKEY: Don't spoil it.
I haven't watched it yet.
VINCE ODDO: I don't
watch "The Bachelorette."
ERIN MACKEY: But, I
mean, yeah, you do.
You do-- you just have to.
It's part of being an actor.
It's part of doing many
shows, and this is definitely
one of them where--
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND:
Their whole weekend-- Friday,
two Saturday, one Sunday,
it's kind of-- Sunday night
is a wipe-out.
And then Monday
is a re-grouping.
And then here's Tuesday.
And they start tonight and
go through next Sunday.
It's a heavy job.
It's heavy lifting.
Eight times a week.
VINCE ODDO: It-- I
mean, it is a heavy job,
but I think the
other thing, too,
is we all got into
this for a reason.
And the fact, like, for me
personally I-- you know,
you work so hard
to get to Broadway
because that's the pinnacle.
It's the top.
And once you're
there you just want
to make the most of the
fact that you're there.
And we're so privileged to
have to do eight shows week.
You know, I've also
shoveled for 12 hours a day,
and I really like
doing plays instead.
ALAN SEALES: Should I ask
what you were shoveling?
VINCE ODDO: I worked
construction, so it was like--
ALAN SEALES: So
literally shoveling shit
or metaphorically
shoveling shit.
VINCE ODDO: Yeah,
yeah, the-- both.
ALAN SEALES: Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, yeah.
This goes along with
what you just asked.
Since you're doing the
same role every night--
I have a couple different
parts of this question,
but-- since you're doing the
same role every night at what
point do you feel
comfortable enough to say,
tonight I'm just going to try
something crazy for this part?
And can you talk
about an experience
that you've had where
you're like, I'm just
going to do something
a little bit
different in this aspect
of maybe the play?
And how it worked out?
And if it worked or
if it didn't work,
or how it changed how you're
continuing on with the play,
or you know?
ERIN MACKEY: I mean,
yeah, definitely.
There certainly are limitations
as to how much changes
we can make once we've opened
the show, once the show is
what we call "frozen."
So the show is set in terms
of where-- pretty much
where we're going to be moving.
Because you don't want
to throw-- I mean,
you've got set
pieces moving, you've
got other people onstage.
ALAN SEALES: It's all
automated, so you'd-- like,
the hydraulics will
take an arm off.
ERIN MACKEY: I mean, we have
people calling the cues.
But, yeah you have
to-- there does
have to be a sense
of consistency.
But within that, I mean,
we try new stuff every day.
We listen to each
other, and we imagine
that we're in that moment.
And we know the
circumstances, and we
know the places
we need to get to,
but the way we get
there every night
is a little bit different.
Every single night.
Depending on what's
happened in our day.
That affects me.
LAIONA MICHELLE:
It's not so much
that we-- oh, sure, you
want to speak on this?
DAN: Hi, I'm Dan.
I'm in the pit--
[INAUDIBLE] keyboard.
And being from where I am,
it's a very flexible show.
It has a breath
and an immediacy.
There are a lot
of shows now that
are to click tracks throughout
the entire production,
so everything is kind
of forced on a routine.
And there are only two
spots in this whole show
that our click-tracked, and
it's for very specific safety
reasons because of mechanical
things going on on stage.
But we have an all acoustic pit.
So we're very
present, as opposed
to some shows where they're
in completely different floors
or different buildings.
I don't have-- I'm not
using any sort of headphones
for everything.
Everything is very
live, immediate.
And that allows the conductor,
and in turn the orchestra,
to be very responsive to
the impulses on stage.
And I can attest,
every day the tempos
shift slightly based on the
energy, based on the audience.
And it's a relatively
intimate house.
We have what, 1,162?
As opposed to some of the
other theaters with three
different balcony levels.
And it really allows for a
unique performance every day.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
So we are out of
time here already.
But in closing, is there
anything specific--
I guess we've talked about it.
I was going to say
is there anything
you want people to come
away from with the show.
But the-- having conversations
and bringing things
to the forefront of their
minds, and just, I guess, not
ignoring problems is what this
show-- I guess, in my opinion--
one of the underlying
messages of this whole show.
So, I applaud you guys for
doing this eight times a week,
putting yourself into it.
God, like you guys
are just amazing.
Everybody go see this.
"Amazing Grace" at the
Nederlander Theater.
208 West-- 208
West First Street,
between seventh and eighth.
AmazingGraceMusical.com.
Please, give them a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
LAIONA MICHELLE: Thank
you for having us.
Thank you.
CAROLYN ROSSI COPELAND: Great.
Thank you so much.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.